how's the day so far I think when she
get team a little Mexican hat course I'm
gonna save you I'm gonna be terrified
but of course
[Music]
all right believe nation welcome to day
5 of our Caribbean adventure featuring
today Nina and Richie and Heath we're in
Cozumel we're supposed to go to a theme
park called census but the fast ferry
from Cozumel to Playa del Carmen there's
a travel advisory not to take it because
of terrorist activities now the US
government is issuing a travel warning
for Playa del Carmen we need to adjust
our plans difficult we're gonna do today
instead stay on the island of Cozumel
but first stop is to get some food and
then there go we're gonna do
[Music]
mushrooms chocolate roll Raisin Bran
they have beef congee hate is not
feeling so well today just gonna have
some water Nima's back she got her
congee Nina loves congee how is it nice
[Music]
it is a windy day here in Cozumel two
places we have to visit one is the
downtown pier where there's supposed to
be tons of activity and two is a place
called Plaza del Sol Plaza the Sun which
has a vibrant area lots of shopping and
people to see so that's we're going to
grab a cab
hop out there and see what we see
[Music]
looking good mr. ho
you
we found the Starbucks and I think I'm
gonna have one too today finally
[Music]
right Cheers how is it
oh yeah that's good I've been missing
this usually every stop on a cruise on a
trip wit number Starbucks and I've been
missing it so
oh yeah I'm mystified
better how's the day so far what do you
want to say all right
message from the wise a declare my girl
right there sipping on the ice cash no
Pacino ordered from the Starbucks secret
menu
cotton candy Frappuccino
is it thumbs up to the cotton candy all
right okay
check it out next time guys any
Starbucks to have a New Mexico Jen
around the world I think what you get
team although a Mexican hat it's a
little too small a little team oh there
you go for your star boy Lena are you
missing team oh not really thinking
about her actually yeah it's gonna sink
in soon though boys you like it
[Music]
Hayden's getting the bracelet is lucky
I like your shirt though
[Music]
oh that's scary that's I'm scary
[Music]
all right we are on our way to la misión
which is one of the eyestrain and
authentic Mexican restaurants here in
Cozumel
so Mina's gonna they're famous for their
what are the famous worth their soup to
kind of suit tortilla chips soup and so
we have to go there for Nina so we're
close
let's go eat looking good guys looking
good
I like the sunglasses eight and
[Music]
okay Cheers
[Music]
good lemonade all right nice here try
the soap
No they're famous guacamole okay Nina
gotta bite
I'm gonna try it myself
oh very funny
like
super fresh guacamole
[Music]
all right it's soup time for Nina
tortilla soup
avocado
[Music]
the chicken what is that you like it
Lena loves her seat
now he's coming he's coming
no no the other one
oh yeah I think it is what is this
Lobster okay give it a shot Nina moment
of truth all right nice oh I am stuffed
that was a quality Mexican meal now
we're gonna continue on with her day do
a little more shopping and then
eventually head back to the boat
[Music]
what do you think mister huh what does
it feel like
thumbs up mister thumbs up
[Music]
so we made it back on board boat got a
few hours or so before heading out for
dinner and that is some perfect time to
film something in spresso videos for you
guys
[Music]
we are taking off heading for where we
headed gran-gran Cayman Islands as our
next journey on our trip but this is a
beautiful view we had all in all eight
different cruise ships today in Port but
not you didn't feel insanely overpacked
but I think we're one of the first ones
to leave so we head off to our next
destination we're gonna beat them there
and make sure we don't have to do
tenders like these guys did I want to
dock right at the pier and walk off my
boat we're gonna go have dinner and
hopefully enjoy here comes the Sun you
got to be the backward all right this is
the Pete's options are today pepperoni
chicken spinach and mushroom that's
gonna be a litter
we've set chicken nuggets olives shrimps
rice corn green beans and mushrooms what
did you get oh hello
give it a shot how's it feeling how's
that Tom Yam is it yummy tummy um yummy
you know we'll always fix soup and all
right it's okay
made by 9h agents you know
that's four that's four cabin desert
this is first round of desert creme
Catalan in s'mores pie hmm the boats
moving a lot we're all getting a little
seasick so you know get my apple crumble
with ice cream and then head downstairs
to our room so it's not as wavy the kids
me and I already left but I gotta get
mad come on ice cream
[Music]
oh right believe nation time to call it
a night another fun-filled day paradise
tomorrow we're hitting up Greinke
maryland's we're gonna do swim with
dolphins and stingrays yeah I haven't
done either before so much you're pretty
post about that you guys I have to swim
if you drown the Dolphins will come and
save you I'll give it I'm gonna save you
ah stingrays of course I'm gonna save
you I'm gonna be terrified but of course
okay thank you for joining us hope you
had an amazing weekend yourself we
believe in you continue to believe and
whatever you want war is much love we'll
see you soon